what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and dc just got done
with their panel at san diego comic-con
at hall h and we pretty much got what we
expected we got a trailer for shazam
fury of the gods and a trailer for black
adam both i thought looked pretty dang
good however sadly there were some
rumors going around that warner brothers
in dc might announce that henry cavill
is back as superman unfortunately that
did not happen despite some pretty big
outlets talking about it but it doesn't
mean that there isn't still hope perhaps
he could appear in a post-credits scene
for shazam or black adam because i truly
would love to see the three of them
fight shazam and superman take on black
adam i think it would be pretty dang
iconic but they did reveal some pretty
cool stuff not only at the panels but in
the trailers as well so let's go ahead
and talk about the entire panel and
let's break down some of these reveals
in this footage now to start off with
actually speaking of superman the rock
did kind of give us a little tease when
talking about who would win in a fight
between black adam and superman this is
what he said because we're all in deep
with this mythology and it's been the
age-old question of who would win in a
fight between black adam and superman uh
pound for pound they're pretty close
um
i i guess it probably all depends on
who's playing superman i will just say
that
[Applause]
so that is a pretty big tease especially
because i'm sure the rock heard about
the rumors of henry cavill possibly
being announced as superman still being
superman at sdcc and showing up at hall
h in which the rock obviously knew he
wasn't going to show up because they
tell him what's going to happen ahead of
time another thing that happened is the
rock actually laid into kevin hart
pretty good which is pretty normal the
two of them are always messing with each
other but a fan asked him if kevin hart
was jealous that he was playing black
adam here was his response
[Applause]
your name
nathan mason but well hold on one second
i'm going to get your question a second
but mason buddy that was a great
question thank you uh the truth is
yes kevin hart gets jealous of
everything
but also i want and i can i'm pretty
good with height you're already taller
than kevin hart
now about dc it kind of seems like they
are trying to do some sort of a soft
reboot warner brothers has obviously
been having a hard time recently with
ezra miller and amber heard and
everything they've been going through it
hasn't exactly been easy on the studio
and even before that fans were really
complaining about the dceu but during
the panel the rock actually teased us a
little bit he said that the goal of
black adam is to usher in a new era in
the dc universe now we're not really
sure what's going to happen in the flash
movie but alternate timelines could be
created and a new dc universe could be
reborn and let's keep our fingers
crossed that that is going to happen
because we need better continuity in the
dc universe and speaking of which they
did actually reveal that amanda waller
is going to be in black adam now what's
interesting about that and is very
obvious about the trailers and the
footage that we have seen for black adam
already is that black adam is not going
to listen to really anybody he's going
to do whatever the heck that he wants to
do so if she's gonna try to control him
that is not going to go very well now
she might be sending the task force
after him perhaps she could even be
behind the jsa but it is interesting
that she is indeed going to be in this
film now in this new footage we get more
about the plot of black adam where he is
trying to decide kind of who he is going
to be and the justice society of america
specifically dr fate who is played by
pierce brosnan in this movie is trying
to get him to use his powers for good to
be a hero and not a villain now the
justice society of america is a good
superhero team and they actually focus
on nurturing superhero legacies and they
even train young and new superheroes and
we actually see some of that in this
trailer and we can tell that the justice
society of america doesn't actually want
to fight black adam but they would like
him to become a super hero someone who
uses their powers for good but of course
like i mentioned black adam doesn't want
to listen to anybody so there's going to
kind of be two fights in the black adam
film black adam going up against the
justice society of america because
they're trying to stop him from being
out of control and destroying everything
this is demonstrated very well in the
first trailer that we got for black adam
where hawkman says heroes don't kill
people and black adam says well i do
claiming that he is not a hero he was
once a slave in ancient egypt his son
was killed and now he has the powers of
a god and kneels before nobody he is not
listening to anyone however the jsa is
trying to help black adam and they are
not the villains of the film the villain
is reportedly going to be sabach who is
essentially the opposite of shazam when
he calls out sabach he gets the powers
of satan em belil bezel bub asmodeus and
kratos and i wouldn't be surprised if
the jsa stepped in and helped black adam
defeat savic but not until we get some
pretty great fight scenes between black
adam and the justice society of america
they actually give us a really really
great scene of hawkman going up against
black adam black adam stopping him with
no problem and then basically shooting
lightning at him so expect a lot of
action coming up in black adam now
during dc's hall h we did get our first
look at shazam fury of the gods and this
is also very interesting because in the
beginning of the trailer it shows the
old justice league they show footage
from the justice league of the flash
aquaman and batman ben affleck's batman
of course confirming that this still
exists in that same universe which is
very interesting because we should
assume that black adam exists in the
shazam universe since they're so heavily
connected plus not to mention the
deleted shazam scene where they all sit
on their thrones but there was one empty
chair that was meant to be for black
adam so they should be in the same
universe which means black adam is in
the same universe as superman as batman
as the flash etc so there is hope for a
black adam versus shazam fight and a
black adam versus superman and shazam
still but in this trailer they show us
that billy batson is actually having a
hard time being a superhero because of
course he's still a teenager despite
looking like a grown-up when he says
shazam and turns into shazam he still
always has the mind of a teenager the
trailer actually opens up with billy
batson expressing his sort of
disappointment in himself to what
appeared to be a therapist but is
revealed to be a pediatrician and during
this time it shows him kind of failing
at being a superhero and having a very
hard time he talks about how cool the
other superheroes are the flash batman
aquaman and how he's not doing a good
job and his family isn't exactly
clicking and zachary levi actually
revealed during the panel he said it's
been a few years since the shazamali
gained their powers and it looks like
there will be some interpersonal family
drama which you kind of see in this
trailer where shazam says everybody's
kind of doing their own thing now and
i'm the only one trying to keep it
together so there will be a little bit
of struggle between the shazamali but
i'm sure they'll come together at the
end of course to defeat the villains who
are revealed in this trailer to be the
daughters of atlas played by lucy leo
and helen mirren helen marin plays
hespera and lucy liu plays calypso and
in this trailer we hear hespera say
children have stolen the power of all
the gods now what's really important to
know here is that obviously since these
are the daughters of atlas atlas was
their father in which the wizard shazam
was the one who actually killed him so
now in this film they are seeking
revenge on anyone with shazam powers now
we see them go to a museum and they find
the shazam staff that was actually used
to kill their father and based off of
what we know about the film they have
found an artifact that can power the
staff so they use this staff as their
main weapon to seek revenge on the
shazam family we see them do some pretty
incredible things with it lucy leo's
calypso even summons a huge dragon now
it's also important to note that they do
actually have another sister and this is
rachel zegler's character but she
actually ends up bonding with freddy
freeman when she comes to earth and her
sisters kind of turn against her so
she's probably going to actually be a
good guy in this movie but the shazam
family and the justice society of
america have their hands full with these
two trailers and hopefully this is a
good sign that dc is heading in a good
direction hopefully all will be revealed
soon in the meantime let me know what
you thought about these two trailers and
the dc panel and of course i'll be
covering marvel's hall h coming up in a
few hours here so don't forget to
subscribe and follow me on instagram and
twitter for live updates as always thank
you all so much for watching woof